a new cdc report gives fresh insight
into the human toll of the pandemic
it says about 300 000 americans who
should be alive
died between late january and early
october
two-thirds of those deaths are directly
blamed on the coronavirus
cdc experts say covin may have played a
role
in the other deaths for example someone
with a heart attack symptoms hesitating
to go to the emergency room
our lead national correspondent david
bagno joins us david what else
is in this report that the excess death
rate anthony amongst those 25 to 44
years old has
jumped 25 this year compared to previous
years
that is the biggest change among any of
the age groups
you know this new information that we're
getting from the cdc is coming at a time
when
a lot of people are actually fighting
over businesses requiring us
to wear these
[Music]
watches a passenger appears to punch a
delta flight attendant in the face
the airline says the passenger was not
following safety instructions
bbc reporters on board the plane say the
traveler
was refusing to wear a mask
the confrontation comes as the cdc is
issuing new guidelines
strongly urging everyone to wear masks
on planes
trains and ride sharing vehicles i wish
they had come out
saying this before but again it's never
too late
north dakota is now leading the nation
in cases per capita
the surge has led to its first mask
mandate in two cities
fargo and minot although the mandate
carries no penalty for non-compliance
south dakota's cases are also among the
fastest growing in the country
with almost 35 thousand confirmed
positive listen to what the mayor of
sioux falls
paul tenhacan who is a republican says
he's hearing
almost daily is this virus even a real
deal
is this the biggest hoax ever so that's
what we're dealing with
for the record the mayor does not
believe in mass mandates
but he does believe everyone should wear
one i need this entire region
to be diligent i need you in northwest
iowa southwest minnesota northeast
nebraska to be doing this as well
because when your people get sick
they're ending up in my city i was one
of those people that
was telling my everybody that it wasn't
real but
it is real samantha williamson wound up
in an oklahoma hospital
infected with the virus she is a mother
of three
who now has this warning sitting in here
it makes you
realize that we take everything for
granted
it's not fake and it is a struggle
wear your mask
miss williamson is expected to be in the
hospital for another two weeks
you know this month alone there have
already been one million new coronavirus
cases in this country
four hundred thousand just in the last
week and gail this made some news
yesterday you know dr francis collins
who is actually the boss of dr anthony
fauci
dr collins runs the national institutes
of health he told npr yesterday that
this thanksgiving he and his family are
not having a celebration he is
calling it off because he is so
concerned about this second wave
that our country is facing i'm following
i'm doing that too
just what francis collins is doing i've
called it off too but david i'm looking
at your report
what has happened to us as a country
that flight attendants who are there to
protect you
are getting hit in the face because they
asked someone to wear a mask and i'm
sorry miss williamson
was is in the hospital but really glad
that she has now changed her tune is
putting that message out there
gail the only thing we can keep doing is
letting you hear from people like miss
williamson who was a non-believer
and now got infected and is like wait a
minute listen to me
it's real you're listening thank you
very much david begnell